à ce moment de notre journal je voudrais
vous parler maintenant d'un mouvement
vieux de 90 ans
les jardins familiaux la génération qui
me précède se souviennent sans doute de
ce que l'on appelait à l'époque les
jardins ouvriers il permit en notamment
à bien des français de se nourrir durant
la guerre est bien les jardins familiaux
c'est une manière sociale disons de
permettre aux français qui n'en n'ont
pas les moyens de pratiquer cette
activité et si hexagonal
alors pour la circonstance gilles
bouleau a revêtu le tablier du jardinier
ici pas de métro et le train toutes les
3 minutes au milieu les potagers à
droite
l'autoroute décibels garantie paris et à
5 km l'espace est très rare la verdure
anachronique
alors pour jardiner heureux il faut
beaucoup d'imagination
la terre elle provient du remblai de
l'autoroute indispensable aussi le
fumier de cheval première qualité en
provenance directe du jardin
d'acclimatation
petite rivière petit pont de bois
fabriqués avec des traverses de chemin
de fer tradition sncf les jardins comme
celui ci il en existe aux forces de 600
villes en france gérées par des
associations qui les louent 300 francs
par an à des ménages modestes
à chacun sa part scène
qu'est-ce que vous plantez le plus ici
dans la salle anne gérer avec des pommes
de terre qui ont été arrachées là c'est
ma deuxième saison de haricots et
tomates et les betteraves rouges défaut
à rodez dans 250 mètres englobant vers
énormément mon sens assez fait pour un
ménage grandement depuis la création en
1896 du premier jardin ouvrier
on ne baisse plus pour les mêmes raisons
le but à l'époque était double il était
d'une part de fournir un moyen
complémentaire de ressources au milieu
des plus modestes aux milieux ouvriers
les plus modestes et également de
fournir d'éléments de détente qui les
sortent de la salle détente dont les
ouvriers venant des campagnes dans les
villes avaient c'est à dire le bistrot
ce qu'on appelait le salon du pauvre à
l'époque un seul point n'a pas changé
ces jardins sont encore aujourd'hui
réservé à ceux qui chez eux n'en ont pas
c'est pas tellement la vie en région
parisienne donc comme fin de compte la
du travail en région parisienne et bat
pour se détendre un peu qui pour changer
les idées c'est spécial ce que vous
signez vous mangez bien si vous ne
mangez que ça vous est aussi les
produits ailleurs à n'en pas pas de
légumes d'ailleurs fendu qui parle à
juste bon la viande mais sinon un petit
peu de fruits et des légumes s'étaient
pas et les considérations financières
les économies ça que vous permettre de
faire c'est important celui qui sans
notre culte bien
ça vaut le coup presque un siècle après
la preuve est faire la passion nourrit
son homme
les chiens aboient le jardinier par as